so we have just seen that a clever trick
based on the frequency interpretation of
the transitions between successive state
like here allows us to write a simple
set of equations which can be solved
recursively even here giving PI I plus 1
as a function of PI of I more
specifically we have pi I plus 1 equals
PI of I times P of I divided by Q of I
plus 1 and this is true for I equals 0
to M and to start the recursion we need
to find PI of 0 and this can be done
using this normalization conditions
which leads to PI of 0 times 1 plus p0
of q1 plus etc equals 1 let's illustrate
the details of this procedure on a
special case let's assume that all the
peas are the same and all the Q's are
the same so this is the special case in
which we are interested in so at each
point in time if we are somewhere in the
middle you have priority P of moving up
and priority Q of moving down define row
to be the ratio of P over Q Rho can be
interpreted as the frequency of going up
versus the frequency of going down if
it's a service system you can think of
it as a measure of how loaded the system
is if P equals Q that means that if you
are at this state you are equally likely
to move left or right so the chain does
not have a tendency to move in that
direction or in that direction if Rho is
bigger than 1 so that P is bigger than Q
it means that whenever we are at some
state in the middle we are more likely
to move right as opposed to moving left
which means that the chain has a
tendency to move in that direction
and if you think of this as a number of
customers in queue it means your system
as the tendency to become loaded and to
build up a queue so row being bigger
than one correspond to a heavy load
where Q's Delta Rho less than one
corresponds to the system where queues
of the tendency to drain down the system
is gonna move in that direction now let
us write down these equations for that
special case we end up with that which
is PI I times Rho by definition of Rho
once you look at this equation then you
realize that PI of 1 is PI of 0 times
Rho and PI of 2 is PI of 1 times Rho
equals PI of 0 times 4 Square and so on
and so forth and you find that you can
express PI of I as PI of 0 times Rho at
the power I for any possible I between 0
and M and now if we use the
normalization condition we get that PI
of 0 times 1 plus Rho plus Rho square
first row at the power M is equals to 1
let's now complete the calculations for
two special cases if Rho is equal to one
that means P equals Q then PI I equals
PI of 0 for all I it means that all the
steady-state probabilities are equal
this special case is called a symmetric
random walk so you start at the state at
a point in time either you stay in place
or you have an equal probability of
going left or right there is no bias in
either direction you might think that in
such a process you will tend to get
stuck either near one end or the other
hand it turns out that no in the long
run this symmetric random walk is
equally likely to be at any other state
and for this special case this equation
here is simply that PI of 0 times 1 plus
M equals 1 that means that PI of 0
equals 1 over 1 plus M which is
consistent with the fact that all steady
state properties are the same they are
all equally likely they are M States and
so each one of them by I is PI of 0
which is 1 over 1 plus M the Markov
chain is equally likely to be in any of
these n plus 1 states in the long run
suppose now instead of P equals Q that M
is very very large a very large number
let's take M going to infinity and
suppose that the system is on the stable
side that means that P is less than Q
which means that there is a tendency for
customers to be served faster than they
arrived in other words the chain is
drifting toward that direction so that
means that Rho is less than 1 and what
it means is that this infinite series
when M goes to infinity is the geometric
series and this race is going to be 1
over 1 minus Rho that is this infinite
series
is 1 over 1 - room
and since power of 0 is 1 over this
infinite series we end up having PI 0
equals 1 minus Rho and since we have PI
of I equals PI 0 times Rho at the power
I we end up having PI of I cos PI of 0
which is 1 minus Rho times Rho equals 1
minus Rho this pi I can be seen as
coming from a private distribution they
tell us that if we observe that chain at
time let's say 1 billion and ask where
is the state of the Markov chain the
answer will be the chain isn't state 0
that is the system is empty with the
probability 1 minus Rho all there is one
customer in the system and that happens
with probability 1 minus Rho times Rho
and so on so the distribution can be
drawn like that you have here hi right
corresponding to a state and if you put
PI of Phi here 0 here then 1 2 3 then PI
of 0 is 1 minus Rho here PI of 1 will be
Rho times Roman and 1 minus Rho and I
have 2 and so and so forth
so if you look at this distribution here
it's pretty much a geometric
distribution except that it is it has
shifted so that it starts at zero
instead of starting at one so it's so
shifted geometric this small is the
first and simple small that one
encounters when studying queueing theory
so a final note the PMF that we have
here as an expected value and the
expectation is given here a of f x of n
is 1 let me write it here is grow over 1
minus Rho and this formula which is
interesting to anyone who tries to
analyze the system of this kind tells
you the following that as long as Rho is
less than 1 then the expected number of
customers in the system is finite but if
Rho this lil Rho becomes very close to 1
then you're gonna have 1 over something
that is very close to 0 and that number
will be very very big so when Rho
becomes very close to 1 that means the
load factor is something like let's is
0.99 you expect to have a very large
number of customers in the system at any
given time